did you hear what he said about reading
your name into the verse
i think that's so powerful and i started
doing that after you mentioned it the
first couple times that you were on our
show and i just went yeah that makes so
much sense and it like personalizes what
you're reading
if you've ever been in bondage would you
like to know how to get free
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live where we use the
light of christ to expose some darkness
only today we're gonna focus on the
light amen very excited about that we
have eric wilson with us again he's no
stranger to our show so welcome back
good to see you again good to see you
again
you know we're going to talk about um
bondage and how to get set free from
that today i don't know about you guys
but
it's easy to get into bondage into
something
and uh if you've experienced true
freedom there's something absolutely
amazing about that so i'm excited to
explore this topic today and eric's
going to teach us how to get set free
i want to i want to let our listeners
our brothers and sisters as well as each
of us know i'm not sharing this because
i thought hey this is a great message to
share i'm sharing this because i was in
bondage
and i found even though i went to church
each week
it's easy to put on the outside and i've
got everything together i'm doing
everything right you know
but you know
in your heart what's inside that's right
nobody else can see that not even my
wife or my children but god can see that
so i would go to church and say happy
sabbath or hi how are you you know and
oh things are great praise the lord and
inside i knew what i was struggling with
whether it be one thing or a hundred
things
so for me
i got to the point where i said
i've got to know if this is real
because yeah because if if all this is
is just changing the outside and inside
i'm still messed up and broken
i'm wasting my time
so that was what that's what caused this
and there's a verse in john chapter 8
verse 32 and it goes down through 36 and
jesus promised us something he said
you shall know the truth and the truth
shall make you free
so that's what we're going to look at
today
so let's go to our our first uh
message our first verse
in this message it's matthew 24 14
our savior said
this gospel of the kingdom shall be
proclaimed in all the world for a
witness unto all nations and then shall
the end come
and growing up as a christian in my mind
i thought well i know the gospel jesus
died for our sins so i don't have to go
to hell
that's what 90 probably 95 of christians
believe
jesus died on the cross so i don't have
to go to hell and that's where it stops
but for a lot of people if you were like
me
i felt like i was in hell here
because
you've got one thing on the outside but
you've got something else on the inside
and now i'm struggling and can't seem to
get free and i couldn't seem to get
answers at church and that really
bothered me
it's interesting though
this verse as well people kind of say
when the gospel goes around the world
then then that's when jesus is going to
come right but we we kind of leave out
that sentence as a witness
and i like how you starred that because
i believe that the gospel needs to be a
witness to everyone does it work
amen and you know it's interesting you
said that because that's why i also put
a star on the word kingdom
the gospel what does the word gospel
mean like
don't don't give us that definition
what does the word gospel literally mean
that god so loved the world that he gave
his own no no not a brother not the
verse
good news
good news or glad tidings so for me i
was like
how am i going to share good news with
somebody if i don't experience good news
how can i tell somebody else jesus came
to set you free if i'm not free
so like what you just said about it's
got to be a witness we can only share
something that we have experienced
personally i can't tell somebody else
how to get free from alcohol
if i've never dealt with that right
right
so it says the good news of the kingdom
and i looked up the word kingdom and you
can do this on any computer program now
with a bible program look it up in its
original greek it means the sovereign
reign
the good news of the king of the
sovereign reign shall be proclaimed as a
witness unto all nations
so the world has to see christ reigning
in us
before they're going to change they
don't need just more doctrines
because i had all the doctrines and i
was still in bondage
yeah i like how jesus always framed the
kingdom as not being necessarily some
physical thing out there it was like the
kingdom of heaven is here it's
he said it's within that's right that's
right
so there's also another verse talking
about the end of the world
revelation chapter 14 verse 6 through 7.
and this is a great chapter if you've
never read it before read it out loud
because there are three angels three
messages that are given here and listen
to what the first one is
the apostle john said i saw another
angel fly in the midst of heaven
having the
everlasting good news glad tidings
to proclaim to them that dwell on the
earth
yea to every nation kindred tongue and
people well this sounds almost identical
to what we just read from jesus
everlasting gospel
so i was like maybe if i start reading
the verses that have the word gospel in
it i might start beginning to understand
what that word really means
so that was the question you know the
gospel you know this was like a picture
of me that's from pilgrim's progress but
that's how i felt i had a 500 pound
backpack on which was wearing me out
and i'm carrying my bible and you know
how come you don't have any joy
how many people call themselves
christians but there's no joy
if there's no joy
there's no freedom
pharisees did not have joy when they saw
jesus and he was smiling and children
were flocking to him it bothered them
they had the rules
and i'm not throwing the rules out but
they did not have freedom and there's a
difference
so i started looking through the
scripture and this is one that that
caught my attention first this is in
galatians chapter 3 verse 6 through 9.
and i encourage our our listeners our
watchers
look up the verses write these down the
references down below because there's
there's a study there that will really
be a blessing to you
it says that the scripture
foreseeing that god would
what's that word
justify
justify the heathen through faith
proclaimed before the gospel unto
abraham just as if i i like amen
never did that
amen ame i've never heard that amen just
if i had never done that that's what
it's that's what it means
and we're going to show that that that's
beautiful i've never heard it put that
way
but this means that the gospel didn't
start when jesus got here in the flesh
the gospel was proclaimed to abraham and
what was the gospel
god said i'm going to justify not the
heathen that have repented i'm going to
justify the heathen so that they can
repent
i don't um
i don't tell you to straighten your life
up so i can heal you i'm gonna heal you
so you can straighten your life up
that's powerful yeah i like that how he
says you know you'll be a blessing to
all every nation not just my people not
just people that believe in me
but anybody you're going to be a
blessing to them and snape yeah because
he says in thee shall all nations of the
earth be blessed who came out of
abraham's loins jesus yeah the promised
child was isaac isaac had jacob and then
you go down the lineage and jesus was
the promised child
so he said in thee
this promise of this blessing is going
to come to every nation on the world now
this might be off topic but when uh
abraham was asked to sacrifice isaac on
that mountain isn't that where jerusalem
was built down the road mount moriah
yeah i mean that's just interesting that
that experience
that you know there's a lamb produced
right there and then it's like you know
the city of jerusalem gets built on
there and that's where the lamb gets
sacrificed it's wild that is wild it's
like all those pieces are there in the
bible it's like when i started really
digging into the bible i was like
i threw out every other kind of book i'm
like i don't want to read stephen king i
don't want to read that junk i don't
want to
why that stuff is like make-believe this
is like real it's deep it's so deep i
mean that's why we'll be studying it for
an eternity and wowed by it like wow
this is crazy wow
amen
now look at what it says in galatians 3
later on verse 16 and then 26-29
it says for unto abraham and his seed
were the promises made
and he saith not and deceits plural
as of many but as of one and to thy seed
which is christ it's funny because this
is new testament quoting old testament
and they knew whether it was plural or
whether it was singular
he quotes what genesis said
it was saint of singular unto thy seed
one which is christ and then in verse 29
this is the best part it says and if you
that means put your name into it if ye
be christ then you are abraham's seed
and you are heirs according to every
promise
i want to hang on this before you get to
that did you did you hear what he said
about reading your name into the verse
i think that's so powerful and i started
doing that after you mentioned it the
first couple times that you were on our
show and i just went yeah that makes so
much sense and it like personalizes what
you're reading yeah and it really i mean
when there was a promise that's made and
you read your name into it it's like
he's saying that to me and you can
i'm we don't live by feeling but let me
tell you something god wants us to have
feelings otherwise he wouldn't have
given us joy and
he wants us to feel his presence
so when i started doing that all of a
sudden it was like i felt god's love i
don't
it's not enough just to intellectually
know that somebody loves you if you
don't feel it
it's like it's a shell
so
let's let's go on i want to go a little
more i put in there your heirs according
to every promise
in the king james it says heirs
according to the promise but the reason
i put every in there is because this
verse
2 corinthians 1 20 it says for all the
promises of god are in him speaking of
jesus
yea and in him they are amen
jesus is the author and the finisher of
our faith
he's the word of god so all the promises
in the word of god are yea
and in the word of god they are all men
does that make sense
so i have to be in christ
so let's say that somebody made a
promise to me let's say my dad was like
a millionaire and he made a promise to
me and he said
eric i'm going to give you when i die
i'm going to give you a hundred million
dollars for your ministry and this is
for you
and it's for anybody that's that's your
seed your children
if my son
realizes that he is my son he knows that
that promise was to him not just to me
does that make sense
so if the promises were made to abraham
and his seed and the seed was christ
if you belong to christ then that
promise that was christ is your promise
and then in second corinthians this is
what it says to us it says
but
if our gospel if our good news is hid
it is hid to them that are lost
in whom the god of this world has
blinded the minds of them that believe
not
and i remember when i was growing up
even as a young man as a christian you
know i sort of thought those lost people
you know so i sort of looked down on
them and the lord one day said eric he
said
a lost sheep you don't look down on
you love them and you want to bring them
home you're not like dumb sheep let the
things stay out there all night it won't
run off again i mean no shepherd would
do that or my my son and my daughter
when they were little say my little boy
goes out and he says daddy i'll be back
i'm going for a walk and he's like eight
years old ten o'clock at night he hadn't
showed back up at eight years old you're
not gonna be like he won't do that again
i'm just going to leave him out there
all night
i mean
but that's how we treat people that
don't understand
the gospel yet
and jesus is like they're lost
i want you to go get them
interesting that the god of this world
has blinded them like you know you talk
to some people that don't really
understand the gospel and they're like
well why would you want to live forever
what are you going to do forever you
know what i mean it's like they've even
been blinded to the
joy that you would feel to be able to
live forever with no pain and no sorrow
and no death and no you know
true yeah and that that's something too
when we talk to somebody sometimes we
can share truth with them and they just
i don't see it and it's easy to go
i showed them i'm wiping the dust off my
feet you know
but god is like
you may have shown it to them but that
doesn't mean they've seen it well i
showed them 100 texts
that still doesn't mean they've seen it
so there's a verse in isaiah 42 16 where
god makes a promise he says
i will open the eyes of the blind i will
turn them from darkness oh actually
that's acts 26 18. i'm sorry let me do
that he says i will open the eyes of the
blind i will turn them from darkness to
light i will turn them from the power of
satan unto god that they may receive
forgiveness of sins
so god has made a promise to open their
eyes so when we find somebody that's
struggling
that's what we've got to do don't beat
them up because they don't see it but go
home and start intercede for them start
getting on your knees and saying god you
promised you'll open that person's eyes
and you can't lie
god can't lie that means if he's spoken
it
the only thing that could stop it from
happening is our doubting it
if we're willing to believe his word
won't fail
and he also promised us in romans 10 17
that faith will come by hearing and
hearing by the word of god because i was
like god i want to believe that promise
but i just can't somehow i can't wrap my
head around it and he said well keep
reading it out loud and after a couple
of days you will believe it and it
really does
so it says the god of this world has
blinded the minds of them that believe
not
so the question that popped in my mind
is
blinding to what
this is a quote from a little devotional
called thoughts from the mount of
blessing it says sin is blinding and
deceiving in its nature
when i'm living in willful sin
it's hard to see the gospel i mean even
as a christian if i know i shouldn't be
doing this
and i'm doing it anyway it's it's more
difficult to see the light
so sin that's what satan's main purpose
is because it blinds us to the truth of
what god's word is saying
that that was the question
sin is blinding to what what does it
blind us to
the truth
in john 17 17 jesus said
he lifted up his eyes unto heaven and
this is right before he went to calvary
this is the longest prayer in the bible
right before he went to calvary he said
father
sanctify them through thy truth yea thy
word is truth
he said like the word sanctified means
to make holy or to make clean or to make
pure
he says i want you to do that through
your truth
i grew up thinking truth was correct
doctrine
we've got the truth you know i i know
the truth
that's not what the word means
one day when the lord was helping me
with this he said eric look up the word
truth so i looked it up in the greek and
this is what the actual definition is
the unfailing verity of god's word
he said sanctify them through your truth
through the unfailing verity of your
word that god that makes a lot of sense
when jesus is like i am the way the
truth and the life and why he would say
verily verily i say he said of a surety
this cannot fail i'm telling you
something amen because my word say it it
happens amen my word can't return unto
me void he said in isaiah 55.
now this is listen to this because we're
talking about truth look at this promise
in micah chapter 7.
this is what satan
even with christians this is what he
tries to hide from us
who is a god like unto thee
that pardons iniquity the word iniquity
means perversity and mischief
perversity means crookedness
and that can be morally crooked as well
as any other kind of crooked
he says who is a god like unto thee that
pardons iniquity that passes over or
passes by the transgression of the
remnant of his heritage the word
transgression means rebellion and
apostasy
he retaineth not his anger forever
because he delights
in mercy
he will turn again
people ask me sometimes they'll say well
how do you know that's god's will if you
can find one verse in the bible where
god said i will do something then you
know that's his will because he just
said i will
he will turn again when i was in bondage
i can remember i felt like i couldn't
even get god to hear my prayers
i mean there was a day where i was just
like and the devil was telling me you've
committed the unpardonable sin you've
grieved the holy spirit you've done this
too many times you've gone too far and i
mean i was battling with that for almost
two weeks
and the lord was like i will turn again
and i was like all right wait a minute
jesus said the devil is a liar and the
father of lies but he is the truth his
word is truth god you said you will turn
again and the lord told me read it out
loud thank you god you promised that you
would turn again
you will not hide your face from me
forever and then the lord was like oh
yeah eric by the way i also promised
i'll never leave you nor forsake you
so god will turn again cause his face to
shine on us
he says i will have compassion upon you
he
will
subdue our iniquities
and thou will
cast all of our sins into the depths of
the sea
we've got to believe that
now look at what the next verse says
thou wilt perform thy truth unto jacob
and thy mercy unto abraham which thou
has sworn unto our fathers from the days
of old
truth the unfailing verity of god's word
israel had committed terrible sins i
mean they were doing
abominations i mean like sacrificing
their sons and daughters to idols they
were doing all kinds of sexual
immorality they had idols everywhere
they were doing every kind of wicked
thing you could possibly imagine
and god says i will perform the truth
that i promised that i swore
that i swore with an oath unto abraham
yeah you read the account of all the
kings and it's like this king did worse
than his father and this team did worse
than his father and so on and so forth
for a while down the road and it's like
how bad can it get and they just kept
getting worse and worse and worse so
it's neat that yeah micah records like
god promising like i'll turn you around
you know it's nate too and and
this really stuck with me there was one
king above every other that was said to
be the worst king that had ever been in
israel was it a uh
manasseh yeah i mean he did things that
were like
wicked wicked bad worse than herod was
he the one that sod
i i don't remember but as isaiah
prophets in half i don't remember that
was him gnarly but what was amazing was
this manasseh god sent him into
captivity
to
you know the apostate you know
nations yeah babylon
yeah i don't think it was babylon
i don't remember i don't remember which
one it was we can look that up but
he sent him into captivity and it says
while he was in prison in a pagan nation
as king you know they're not going to
treat you good
it says he humbled himself greatly
before the lord and god forgave him and
put him back on the throne
i mean he was the wickedest man that had
ever been king ever
and god forgave him what a testimony
right amen
now you know and i've had some people
tell me before well you're being liberal
you know all you're focusing on is god's
mercy and i was like well by mercy and
truth iniquity is purged
the apostle paul tells us in romans 6
shall we continue in sin so that grace
may abound
god forbid how shall we that are dead
unto sin continue to live therein when
you realize how much god loves you and
what has been done for you
you hate sin because you know what it
did to your savior
and i've had to ask the lord give me
that go ahead alex no interesting what
you're saying about truth you know the
word of god uh you hear i mean you see
in the history of this world i mean the
enemy of the souls always attacking
the bible
always attacking you know uh
i mean you see the you know like i say
you know in the history you know this
group growing up you know and they want
to share the gospel and the enemy want
to just destroy here and you know and
friends and different parts of the world
you know as
groups they want to uplift
the word of god and the enemy you always
want to serve what about now
yeah i mean you can i mean you can name
different groups or different things
that they hate the word of god even even
like with what you guys do a lot with
your ministry
look at how hollywood and the music
industry caused people to doubt god's
word oh yeah it was one shadow of doubt
that caused adam and eve to fall
one did god really say boom they're gone
what about evolution that's being taught
in our schools that's the whole purpose
if you take a child from you know third
grade till you know
12th grade and they're learning
evolution every day they go to school
they're hearing doubts being whispered
to them by the enemy
they go to church one day a week for
three hours but eight hours a day five
days a week they're hearing evolution
it's like the very first chapter of the
bible the devil was like i'm gonna get
you to not believe that
and then the rest of it you want that's
right that's right
so he promised he would perform the
truth
that he had sworn to abraham now let me
show you this is neat because that was
old testament look where it actually
tells what that truth was
it's in luke chapter 1 verse 67 through
that we should be saved
from our enemies
and that means the devil and all his
angels
and from the hand or power of all those
that hate us
to perform the mercy
promise to our fathers and to remember
his holy covenant
even the oath which he sware to our
father abraham
that he would grant unto us
that being delivered out of the hand of
our enemies we might serve him without
fear in holiness and righteousness
before him all the days of our life
do you know what hit me about this two
things
it says so that he would remember his
holy covenant and i grew up thinking
well that covenant is holy it's like
this rolled up scroll and it's special
that's not what it means
in hebrew they read from right to left
it's
covenant
holy the word covenant is an oath and a
promise it just said that right there
even the oath which he swear
it's a oath and a promise to make us
holy
he swore to us in leviticus chapter 11
and leviticus 19 that he would make us
holy
and he said i'm going to do it
i had to i had somebody ask me one time
they were like yeah but you got to do
your part
and i was like okay so what did the
children of israel do in order to get
god to come get them out of egypt
people were like well they repented no
they didn't when you read the old
testament history from the day almost
day one after they got out of the the
egyptian bondage they're at the red sea
and they start murmuring and then they
get through the red sea
go for a couple of days and it's good
and then they start complaining then
they start sinning and then they've got
idols and it was just one apostasy after
another
in psalms it actually talks about that
and god said i did not let you all go
for your sake or because of any
righteousness you had i did it because i
swore an oath unto abraham
300 years before that i would set you
all free
and so like this experience that the
israelites were having is is sort of a
you know god always has this micro
version of something that's larger
that's something that's larger so we can
read these stories and be like wow he he
set these people free that didn't
deserve it what does that mean that's me
what does that mean for me like i mean
you know what i mean i'm in bondage to
the systems of the world and it's like
god is promising i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna be your savior amen amen
the other thing in this verse that
caught my attention is look what it says
right there
brittany would you read from the second
beginning of the second paragraph down
to where the color of the verse turns
blue okay
even the oath which he swear to our
father abraham that he would grant unto
us
grant how many people have ever been to
school like college
what's the difference between a school
loan and a grant you don't got to pay
the grand back yeah alone you've got to
pay it back
with interest on time that day
that's right how many of you want a
grant
god said that he would grant unto us and
that's what it means it means literally
a gift
a gift undeserved
amen
this was neat alex you and i were
talking about this
one of the most powerful verses in the
new testament that explains the gospels
in romans chapter 1 verse 16 and 17.
listen to what it says the apostle paul
was writing he said i am not ashamed of
the gospel the glad tidings of christ
read that for us alex yeah because it is
the power of god into salvation to
everyone that believeth
so the gospel is the power of god
that's like wow i never heard that
before the gospel is the power of god
that's what it says i'm not ashamed of
the gospel of christ for it is the power
of god
unto
salvation
to everyone that believes
now this is the this is the part that
gets really exciting
salvation
i grew up hearing and being taught and
thinking that salvation means
finally one day i get to get into heaven
so i was like okay so when am i going to
know for sure when am i going to have
assurance that i'm going to be in i mean
people live in fear you can't have
assurance you can't say you're saved and
i would have friends of mine that went
to different churches they were like are
you saved and i was like man i don't
know how to answer that and the lord
asked me he said eric he said you don't
even know what the word saved means i
said yes i do it's when you get into
heaven and the lord said
you don't know what it means why don't
you look it up
so i looked it up and look at what the
lord showed us
the top numbers are the greek words for
saved or salvation the
bottom numbers the h that's the hebrew
so in greek the word saved means rescued
safety deliverance freedom
healing and restoration wow
now in my mind i was like when i first
opened it up i was like man there's all
these definitions how do i know which
definition is the right one
and i asked the lord i looked up and i
said which one's the right definition
you know what he said
which one do you need today
and i was like and i mean like the hair
on the back of my neck stood up and i
almost started crying but i was like
i think you just said that to me
but i need to see it in the scripture
and he the lord said go right there to
luke chapter four jesus stood up on the
very first sermon he shared in church on
that sabbath day you know what he said
the spirit of the lord is upon me
because he has anointed me to proclaim
glad tidings to the meek to heal the
brokenhearted to set the captives free
to make the lame to walk to i mean all
of it what's even more amazing is the
jews heard him say that and realized the
significance of what he was saying
and got mad at him
yeah like kicked him out
that's crazy it is but aren't we doing
the same thing yeah we're trying to
share the gospel to other people and
they're like get mad you know like hey i
don't want to hear about you jesus yeah
do you know what's funny
the world will say i don't want to hear
about jesus the church will say you're a
fanatic it can't be that easy what do
you mean i just got to believe and i'm
like what about cornelius i mean you
know
some of the disciples were like really
upset well he's got to be circumcised
he's got to do this he's got to do that
peter said
he accepted christ the holy spirit fell
on him just like he did on us and
everybody was like
you know what do we do with that you
know and then paul comes along and then
they really got worked out
it's like they don't
people that are legalistic don't want to
see mercy shown
and people that are liberal don't want
to know the truth that god's going to
make us holy
so you've got these two extremes that
the devil is sending people to
look at what it means in hebrews
salvation or saved it means deliverance
to aid to give victory
health to open wide to set free to
support to defend
to preserve
and to get victory now here's what's
crazy
ask anyone anyone you just walk into
them on the street hey do you like
healing hey do you like restoration do
you like being set free do you want to
be rescued from something do you want to
get a victory deny that
you like salvation oh
back up back up what are you talking
about that's a good point you know what
i mean
those are desirable things for every
single person on the face of the planet
i don't care if you believe or you don't
believe we all would like that
amen isn't that interesting amen
amen
i want to read a quote from
probably one of my favorite books
outside the bible it's called the desire
of ages i encourage our brothers and
sisters that are watching if you've not
read that book read a chapter a day read
a couple of pages a day it will change
your life
but don't put the bible to the side keep
it with you
listen to what it says on page 8 23 it
says this world is a vast lazar house
and we don't use that word anymore not
very common but it means a house that's
full of the sick and dying
but christ came
to heal the sick and proclaimed
deliverance to the captives of satan
it's not two separate things
those that are sick are being held sick
by satan do you remember the woman that
came to church that one day and she was
all bowed over and jesus was there and
he's watching the pharisees and he saw
the woman that was sick and he was
thinking they're going to get so mad if
i heal her because they say it's the
sabbath you can't do this that's working
and he was like you know what he said
lady come here and he put his hand on
her and healed her she stood up straight
instantly
i mean
wow and then he looked at the pharisee
and said pharisees and he said ought not
this daughter of abraham
be
loosed from her bond
that she's been bound by satan lo these
i don't remember how many years 18 years
satan was causing the sickness and i
don't want people to misunderstand me
you understand
christ came to set the captives free
then look what it says
how he did this
he was in himself health and strength
he imparted his life to the sick the
afflicted and even those possessed by
demons
do you know when someone's possessed and
i'm not talking about crazy their head
spinning around backwards and vomiting
or cutting themselves i'm talking about
there's people in church that are
possessed by demons selfishness and
bitterness and lust and
you name it
a demon will say when when a man of god
or a woman of god is there to pray a
demon will say i'm not leaving i'm not
leaving because they opened the door and
god your word says whoever they yield to
that's whose slave they are romans 6 16.
the demon says i'm not going anywhere i
got every right to be here they opened
the door let me in i'm staying
jesus said well there's only one way to
fix this
i'll take their life from them which
includes their sin and i give them my
life what right do you have to stay
there now
oh we're leaving boom they're
so he turned and this this brings tears
to my eyes he turned away none who came
to receive his healing power i have went
through the new testament multiple times
there is only one person in the entire
new testament scriptures that god said
no i'm not going to heal you don't ask
anymore and that's when she asked for
the crumbs no that was the paul
paul was blinded and god restored his
sight but it wasn't 100
because paul was the author of most of
the new testament but he only wrote to
the best of my knowledge one of the
letters somebody else had to write for
him because his eyesight was not 100
and one of the letters he even tells
them he says i bear witness that if it
were possible you would have given me
your own eyes
but you know what paul didn't go for 50
years wondering why he was you know
didn't have perfect vision
he asked god and god answered him on the
third time god was like paul don't ask
me anymore this is from my glory it
keeps you humble trust me and paul was
like i'm free now no problem done amen
he turned away none who came to receive
his healing power and this really i love
this
jesus knew that those who petitioned him
for help had brought disease upon
themselves
yet he did not refuse to heal them
you know what the pharisees say
you made your bed lie in it as a man
soweth so shall he reap they quote
scripture
that's why they kept attributing those
those those things to they sinned that's
right
the devil will speak that
that's what the bible says and they're
quoting the scripture jesus said have
you never read in the scripture
if you had only known or understood what
this meant i would have mercy and not
sacrifice
when virtue from christ entered into
these poor souls they were convicted of
sin and many were healed of their
spiritual disease as well as their
physical maladies
the word virtue is dunamis it's where we
get our word dynamite it means
miraculous power supernatural power
and then look what it says the gospel
still possesses the same power and why
should we not today
witness the same results
i mean it's it's true it's hard to it's
hard to argue with that statement
but when i really put the rubber to the
road i mean have you ever seen anyone
healed
what would you do if you saw that
i mean not
like that i mean but it says it could be
possible right and i'm also it leads me
to the question um
is healing always immediate
because i it's like
you hear a lot of testimonies of people
saying i like
i prayed and it was gone all at once
and it's like what if for some people
it's a process
you know yeah i don't i don't like i
don't struggle with that i mean i know
like i've had that question
what i have found is is that
what god wants like it said there christ
imparted his life
so what he's asking from us is a
surrender
so am i willing to surrender or sir like
is the does the enemy have a foothold
like like maybe like i'm a glutton and
i'm struggling with appetite and then
i've also got this disease that's
because of appetite and god's like i've
got to get you to let go of that
appetite so that i can take the disease
away and for some people that's that's a
process it takes a little bit longer for
them to for christ to win their trust
and to win that part of their heart
where they go you know what other people
are like they've smoked cigarettes for
30 years and god convicts them and
they're just like i'm done
and other people will battle for 20
years to get rid of them it's not that
god's power is different it's that the
surrender of the heart takes longer with
some people
so do you think there is some type of
reconciliation that needs to happen for
an individual before they can be free so
let's say
you have someone who
um i don't know had a terrible family
and like you know as a christian you
have to forgive
so
it
how do you go from forgiving or like i
guess where's the line between forgiving
and completely ignoring
like how you feel okay you know because
i i feel like sometimes you have to
process and actually forgiveness
shouldn't be something like
you just dismiss everything that you
feel but it should be something that you
generally like your heart has been
changed amen i agree
and i'm going to share i'm not going to
go into details but i'll share from my
own life
i was in ministry
number of years ago and
went to see
our family
we had like my side of the family we had
a big get together i don't remember it
was thanksgiving or whatever and uh my
grandmother was there and she's talking
and she brought up a family member
that had hurt a number of the children
in our family and almost everybody in
the family almost i'd say half the
family knew
what this man had done
um
i hated the man
i mean like i'm i'm in ministry go to
church preach
but i mean when they mentioned his name
that day i would have just assumed spit
as to said his name and i looked at my
grandmother when she brought him up and
i just said i don't i said i would i
would spit on the ground rather than
mention his name that's my grandmother's
brother
and
you know that was the end of it it was
like everything just got really quiet
you know and and we got in the car and
went home that evening and my wife was
in the car with me on the way home and
she said
eric she said
your great uncle is dead
she said but you're still carrying all
this resentment towards him because of
what he did to family members
and i looked at it i got angry she said
something to me i was like look you know
there's nothing about that man that was
good
and i went home and for the rest of that
week every morning i would get up to
have worship i couldn't even have
worship i'd go in there and i'd sit in
my office and i'd open my bible and it
was just just words on a page
and i was like god what is wrong you
know what do you want me to read and we
had a little booklet on how to get free
from bitterness and resentment and
unforgiveness i'd never read it we'd had
it for years sitting there and i'm like
lord what do you want me to read what am
i doing and i look up and there's that
booklet and i was like i'm not reading
that i mean i'm not reading it
and then it was like every single day
and finally at the end of the week i was
like okay i said okay lord i can't go
because i'd went a whole week without
hearing his voice
i opened that book up and i read it
probably in two days it was just a
little booklet
i can send it as a pdf if somebody's
struggling with that it is the most
powerful thing i've ever seen
but unforgiveness and resentment and
bitterness is probably the number one
sin
in christian lives
and it does stop
the window from heaven and the reason
why is because christ lives inside of us
and he's already forgiven that man that
hurt the members of my family so when i
say i'm not going to forgive him it
stops that flow
and the flow goes both ways
that's why jesus said if we do not
forgive every person every wrong they've
done to us neither can he forgive us
because it stops that flow how is that
fair you're asking for forgiveness which
you do not deserve
and yet you are unwilling to give it to
somebody well my struggle was like
and this was hard brittany because i'm
reading this book and it made it clear
it helped me
but i told the lord i said god i said
what he did was wrong
i don't want to forgive him but i see
you're telling me to but i'm like i can
say i forgive him but inside
i can't get rid of this thing that's
inside this animosity towards this
person
and then the lord made it clear and i
mean like he spoke just clear to me he
said eric are you willing to suffer the
abuse that he
caused and i said what do you mean he
said are you willing to suffer the pain
are you willing to accept the pain
rather than saying i'm not going to let
that hurt me
and i just i said i told the lord i said
i don't want to and he said
nothing i mean it just got real quiet
and then i was like i knew because his
spirit was speaking to me and i was like
yes sir i said i'm willing
to suffer the pain that was caused
and in my mind i was like man i'd rather
be angry than feel the pain
but the moment i said that i was willing
christ took the pain i never felt the
pain for one minute all i had to do was
say i'm willing and i was like boom it
was gone
all the bitterness was gone like right
now the only thing i can say about that
man was i wish i had been a witness to
him i wish i had had loved him and
shared jesus with him i don't have any
hard feelings i hate that he died and
didn't know christ
before
i would just soon spit on his grave i
mean that was that
so
anyway if anybody's interested let me
know and we will be happy to send you
that booklet as a pdf it's really good
uh we will talk about healing right and
if you're healing if it's not in the
moment or later on
what about obedience
because i had this situation it was kind
of small but i i just want to share this
with you
we were i was in the church and i was in
this class in the church and
this
that the teacher was like
he was a lady he was maybe like
14 people there
and this lady's like you know for three
nights i had this
huge headache
and please pray for me you know and i
please i don't know what's going on like
you said i decided to come to church and
you know
be obedient you know to be here and
please i mean i'm begging god to to
to heal if it doesn't go away you know
and so we pray you know you know stuff
to start class stuff like that
and
during that prayer inside of me i'm not
kidding you it's like the lord is like
get up and go over there and kill and
pray over her
and i'm like
kind of like
you know sometimes like i don't
understand up and go
so i was just wrestling with the lord
i'm not kidding be honest to you i was
like i'm not gonna go and you know
they're praying everything right inside
of me it's like i'm sweating and all of
that
and
and no i'm serious i i just the lord
told me get up and go over there and
pray over
it's not about you it's about me hang on
his power
so when they say amen and i'm like
yeah
how am i gonna say that to the lady you
know and you know my wife's on the next
i mean i mean there were good friends
and everything very we like
and i say hi um
he says excuse me leo hey uh i
i need to i need to do something and
she's like yeah sure what is it
and now you stand up and i said i don't
know i mean during the prayer i mean
it's like the lord told me to they're
gonna be
pray for you and it's gonna remove that
i mean that's what i had that experience
and i mean can you imagine to say that
if that thing it doesn't go away i mean
i know you feel like you're a fault
i mean i was like that's a heavy thing
so i was like i don't want to deal with
that but i stand up and i say
i just feel the lord told me to i'm
going to pray for you please come
i believe in that too you know so i just
put whole hands i mean i know a special
man i just hold her you know
as i pray
and say man and everything
when the when the classy was over
i mean it's literally like when it was
over like you know she was next you know
see you later stuff like that
and she comes to me with to smile like
differently it's like
my head is gone amen and i was like
really say yeah praise the lord thank
you so much
be obedience to god and i'm like
wow can you imagine if you're not
obedient amen yeah so it's
towards you the heavy lotus on you
knowing her
so she's trying to be healed and he said
why is not god is answering my prayer so
to me it's like
maybe god is gonna be maybe using
somebody else to taste the faith amen or
that person to are you obedient to me
amen are you thinking like oh no you
know so i just want to share that with
you i'm glad you shared that yeah that's
that's powerful yeah so me and that and
then between the prayer i mean i was
sweating i was like i don't want to be
ridiculous you know i'm going to stand
up better but i was like yeah i can do
that you know i believe in that
the inside and you're just like i don't
want to stand up you know stuff but i
was like no i'm going to be a good
listener god said that and i'm going to
do it amen and it was it was it was it
was great so obedience i just wanted to
share that with you amen
i'm glad you shared that out
and it's funny because there's a verse
coming up that
talks about that
matthew chapter nine as well as matthew
chapter eight do you know what jesus
said
according to your faith be it unto you
as thou has believed
according to your faith and i was like
so what if you don't believe
read the promises out loud with your
name in it and the faith will come
because god promised it will
the scripture says whosoever believeth
on him
jesus the word of god shall not be put
to shame
so
we've got to believe god's word
now for me it's like
that's why i don't want to watch
hollywood i don't want because i don't
want my faith to be gone
i want to be like god said it
and and hopefully here in another show
we're going to talk about that wrestling
with god i'm going to share some of what
happened with my wife when she was
praying for me you know my wife prayed
for me for almost five years
and god heard
but she fought the fight of faith we've
got to believe what god says no matter
what we see no matter what the doctor's
report says no matter what the enemy is
whispering even through our friends and
family
i don't care what you said god said
different
amen amen praise god so back to romans 6
it says i am not ashamed of the gospel
of christ for it is the power of god
unto salvation
to everyone that believeth so having
faith is what's important salvation for
what
sin and all its results
that's why salvation is healing
yeah all of that
do you know one of the hebrew words for
salvation it actually includes
financial blessings it actually says
that to prosper financially
and that i'm not preaching the
prosperity gospel but you know what god
wants to bless his people so that we can
bless other people
he does when the children of israel left
egypt it says the egyptians gave them
all kinds of wealth on their way out so
they could build a temple for god and
the israelites didn't know that's what
it was for
he says for everyone that believeth for
therein is the righteousness of god
revealed god's faithfulness his
righteousness is revealed from faith to
faith as it is written
the just shall live by faith amen now
that we're justified or justification
this is what the greek and hebrew
definitions are
to declare to render innocent
just pure clean holy righteous and
perfect just as if i never did that
thing in the fridge i'm i've got to get
you to email that to me but that's true
it is terrible
that's true to be justified means it's
you're clean
there's not like god's got like
something stuffed down here where he's
keeping everything written down that you
ever did wrong god said i wiped it away
he actually says two times in isaiah
isaiah 43 and isaiah 44 i have blotted
out as a thick cloud by transgressions
and as a cloud thy sins the devil's the
one with the mirror that's right
he's the accuser he's the one that
brings the list and god's like well my
list has nothing on there but the
picture of jesus that's an important
concept because you know so much of when
we when we trip and we fall and we beat
ourselves up and you know it's the devil
that's sitting there going look at what
you've done like what you've done look
who you are look who you really are deep
down inside you know and this is a neat
thing that that
he's rendering us innocent
yeah he's not claiming the guilty he's
he's like no i'm gonna i'm gonna wipe
that slate clean if you just ask hey
ma'am too amen
now here's a verse that all of us know
somebody read that for me it's first
john 1 9.
if we confess our sins god is faithful
and he is just
romans 3
26 to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us
of all unrighteousness
for john 1 when i have fallen when i
have messed up
i focus on the forgiveness and the devil
will keep you there on the forgiveness
but it also says and cleanse us
of all
unrighteousness it means it's not right
god says i've wiped all that away it's
gone you never did it
i like that it adds that to cleanse us
from all because you know it didn't it
could have easily just hung there and
said i'm going to cleanse you from the
thing that you just did but it's like it
adds this extra layer to it that's like
everything you know just that thing that
you're you're asking for confession for
it's everything and remember this is the
gospel that has to go to the world
not jesus died for my sins so i don't
have to burn in hell well that's fine
but what about today
how do i walk in freedom today because
he forgave me for something yesterday or
last year
he cleansed me
now look at this statement
study the scriptures
know that the only thing in which we can
safely glory is that which will open to
us the gates of the city of god
learn from the word of god that means
from jesus how to form characters fitted
for the country you are seeking
know that christ is to be set forth
among or within you and that all that
was lost in adam the cross of christ
fully restores to every believing soul
people go well i know that'll happen in
heaven god's like
i want it now i want it to happen in
your life now all that was lost by adam
the cross of christ fully restores
in isaiah chapter 45
then this is our closing verse this is
beautiful
he actually promised this
he said look unto me
and be
ye saved not try to be he said be
where did god first say that
let there be
light
and there was it didn't take a week for
it to get there it didn't take a year it
was the third day god god spoke it and
it was second day
look unto me and be ye
free
healed
made whole
all the ends of the earth for i am god
and there is none else god speaks things
he declares things and makes them right
so when we can get salvation when is the
perfect time to go to jesus
let me read it to you i don't have it on
the screen i apologize but in second
corinthians chapter 6 verse 2 listen to
what it says
for god saith i have heard you in a time
accepted and in the day of salvation
have i rescued or succored thee behold
now is the accepted time behold today is
the day of salvation
you know if you would have gotten bit by
a snake
i don't think you'd make an appointment
you didn't mean to go look at it i think
you'd be immediately like take my bed
out there and let me just see this thing
um and i think that that's such a simple
illustration for us and how we need to
come to god
now the problems now today don't wait we
don't need to clean up before we get
there it's like you know in whatever
state you can turn your eyes a simple
thing to do like that look and live god
promises he will save us amen and then
if the enemy starts beating you up with
it can't be that simple just read out
loud write them down on index cards god
said this
if you come to me him that cometh to me
i will in no wise cast out say it over
and over again amen the blood of jesus
cleanses me from all sin all my sins
were on him 2 000 years ago he died i'm
free amen powerful powerful amen
we hope you guys were blessed by today's
talk uh it is simple look and live
that's what god is offering to us today
and so whatever you're struggling with
whatever ailment the devil has blinded
you from the truth do not listen to the
enemy god is right there and willing
more than willing to
take us and make us whole make us clean
and if you just ask that
he will answer and he said so in his
word and he cannot lie so amen eric
thank you for coming by and blessing us
once again we hope you guys are blessed
leave us a comment in the in the comment
section below if you want to you know
ask a question comment on something that
was said we love to interact with you
guys and don't forget to give a thumbs
up to um this talk share it with someone
it's no good just sitting in the
computer if you know somebody that would
be blessed by it please
share this information
because it is good news and we want as
many people to hear it as possible we
thank you guys we'll see you guys in a
week
[Music]
you